well that was in Haiti I visited the
école navale garage a a school that
serves some of the poorest children
living in port-au-prince
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
here a lot of giggling he's had a good
side hi don't mind me just gonna join
you just don't mind me I'm good hi I'm
gonna need a little more room up here
forward can I can I try try try new say
ICN no way man take
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
as I was leaving the school I was
suddenly surrounded by my very curious
classmate who's the president United
States now okay his name is Donald Trump
who's heard of Donald Trump me an advil
can you translate Donald Trump was on
television Donald Trump didn't gonna be
gone and then a bunch of grown-ups got
drunk if you appear to glow moon zoo and
they made a president man crazy man with
the crazy hair he became president
that's why I'm moving to Haiti
my wife says I'm crazy you do you think
that she's modernism someone who asked a
question with no you don't think I'm
crazy
oh the president the same question Trump
what did Trump say about Haiti I'm not
going to
[Laughter]
[Applause]
that's cool Monique won once I desire by
the way maybe Americans need to help
Haiti put things back I'm not gonna take
[Music]
[Applause]
that America in history has not been
good to Haiti but there's still a chance
for America to be better to Haiti I
think there's still a chance that sound
good to you now you're talking brah yo
good so you agree with me we make a deal
on that do knock off a deal okay
[Applause]
yeah yeah the faster she tweets does she
tweet in Conway
[Applause]
you